every one it took nvidia ten years to
finalize the real-time rate phasing
technology found within the new geforce
r-tx cards but alas reviewers were given
just five days to review what is
genuinely next-generation graphics
hardware now I hope to cover off as much
as I possibly can here but bear with me
if it's not a complete review as you
would have liked but well I can show you
today is just how powerful the new RT X
cards in relation to their predecessors
and give you an inkling of what the new
cheering architecture delivers and it is
only an inkling cheering offers
real-time raid facing technology and
potentially game-changing performance
enhancing image reconstruction
techniques but right now there are no
games on the market that use them which
makes testing them very difficult indeed
at the very least though I can give you
some first impressions of the new
hardware firstly we're testing the
founders editions cards here which sees
Nvidia move away from its traditional
blower design in favor of a thermal
solution more in keeping with some of
the third-party products you see out
there and dual axial fans propel air
into your case as opposed to out of the
back of it while the fans themselves are
obviously quieter than previous Nvidia
cards the end result are quieter card
obviously and a cooler one as well so
yeah there's a genuine sense of quality
weight and heft to both our TX 2080 and
2080 t.i both of which share an eye on
identical chassis the only visible
difference between them coming down to
an 8 + 8 pin PCI power input
configuration on the TI versus 8 + 6 on
the standard party X 2018 display inputs
are an evolution from that seen under
1080 TI once again dual link DVI has
been consigned to oblivion 4 HDMI 2.0
remains while there were three
DisplayPort outputs in addition to USB C
featuring virtual link a new protocol
designed to reduce the VR headsets cable
nightmare
- one easy-to-handle lead charging extra
cash for the Pascal founders Edition is
always rankled but at least this time
the price premium is matched by the
quality of the chassis and NVIDIA also
adds a reasonable factory overclock on
top so the silicon level then cheering
represents a considerable gamble by
Nvidia real-time ray tracing technology
of the deep learning tensor cause adds
significantly to the size of the core
processor which in turn translates into
a much higher base cost the tinu 102
processor found in the top-end
20 atti 60% larger than its predecessor
while the 2080s tu-104 sees a remarkable
74 percent increase in die area now
combine that with the cutting-edge GD dr
6 memory not to mention the complete
lack of competition in the market and
this possibly explains the high prices
RTX 2080 costs more than 1080 Ti and
well the 2080 Ti is charged at Titan
money with the upcoming fire sales of GT
X 1080 Ti as and retailers clear stock
many may be tempted by a good deal on
the Pascal range so just how profound
are cheering's key features real time
rate facing is considered of course the
holy grail of 3d rendering and we've
seen some remarkable results on the RT x
2080 TI but there are a number of
caveats that need to be factored in
first of all right now obviously there's
a real lack of software and we're
unlikely to see anything until further
into q4 we should expect to see
battlefield 5 here as the big showcase
and what we've seen of it so far looks
quite beautiful with the real-time
reflections beyond anything we've seen
before similarly for a games metro
Exodus reveals how late racing can
revolutionize global illumination again
it's a stunning showcase but there are
three elements to understand here in the
short term firstly developers have only
had limited access to final cheering
Hardware the battlefield 5 demo we
played saw the developers only enjoying
the benefit of
access to final Hardware in the two
weeks leading up to Gamescom the rest of
development spent using older boards
based on the Volta architecture in short
we just took the beginning here secondly
performance is a concern battlefield 5
runs at 1080p north of 60 frames per
second with ray tracing and labeled on
the top end 28 MTI if you're spending
over a thousand pounds or dollars or
whatever on a graphics card is 1080p
really gonna cut it
similarly Metro exoduses Gamescom demo
drops beneath 1080p 60 optimization is
sure to follow and as we shall see
cheering has more tricks up its sleeve
to get the job done but all of this
optimization is going to take time the
final factor to consider is that
everything we've seen so far has been
running on RT x 20 ATT I so where does
that leave the less capable 20 80 and 20
70 right now we don't know but maybe
other chewing technologies can help
boost performance technologies like DL
SS for example deep learning super
sampling the point is that cheering's
architecture is so forward-looking it
contains features that nobody has really
begun to tap into yet which means that
if you buy now you kind of need to wait
to see those advantages so there's a lot
of jan tomorrow here but one feature we
can take a closer look at is indeed DL
SS again there are no shipping titles
using it at launch but we have access to
two demos that show that it may well be
a game changer now John Alex and I will
be talking in more depth about this in a
separate video but performance is the
focus in this one otherwise fundamental
level a lower resolution image is
generated and then a deep learning
algorithm programmatically upscales the
image based on learned behavior sourced
by nvidia saturn v supercomputer
studying extreme resolution game imagery
finding patterns in their composition
and building it all into a
reconstruction algorithm just a few
megabytes in size the bottom line is
this if the actual image being generated
is of a lower as
lucien it stands to reason that shading
power decreases resulting in higher
frame rates so think of this as
checkerboarding with fewer of those
telltale artifacts but again I don't
really think that gives you all the
credit it deserves but anyway so begins
the benchmarking and we will begin by
taking a look at epics infiltrator demo
on the new cards we're able to use DL SS
as well as the standard taa while the
older Pascal flagships 1018 and the t
i-- are limited to standard taa only the
data is clear enough here and gives
potential RT x 2018 buyers in particular
food for thought the 1080 TI remains an
outstanding performer that can match and
sometimes beat the 2018 it has more
memory and it's likely to get plenty of
tempting cut price feels in the short
term however the 2018 here is almost 12%
faster in this bench
however with PLSS active that 12% lead
rises to 58% that is pretty impressive
and it's on par with the kind of
performance police's we saw between 9
Series in 10 series cards in places a
clear divide between Turing and Pascal
products even without the LSS the 2080
offers a 41% performance boost over its
notional predecessor the GTX 1080 and
this increases to a for doubling of
performance once the reconstruction
technique is enabled fascinating stuff
also intriguing is that running with DL
SS enabled allows the RT X 2018 to beat
off the challenge of the 2080 ti when it
doesn't have DL SS enabled in this case
that gives the lower end card a 13.5
percent lead but obviously the 2080 TI
is equipped with the same technology and
up against the GTX 1080 TI it's 39%
faster with the like for like taa
enabled rising to an impressive 95
percent boost once DL SS is factored
into the equation in our general
gameplay testing we found that the RT x
2080 Ti is a phenomenal 4k performer
just relying on standard
stylization performance but d LSS takes
things into a whole new category and
image quality is really decent again
this is something that we'll cover in
depth shortly but again this is a demo
not again however we also have a Final
Fantasy 15 demo to look at this is a
great game but it's standalone
benchmarking tool as seen here is
remarkably poor with often terrible
performance especially when game works
is enabled we were given a versions of
demo with settings lots seemingly to max
yes with game works and performance was
ok that marred by obvious stuttering for
our benchmark we capture three stages of
the bench where the stuttering is kept
to a minimum the idea here isn't to have
tests Final Fantasy 15 as a game with
these two theories but rather to judge
relative performance with the same
workloads from areas that run fairly
smoothly with PLSS enabled and disabled
2080 performance with standard TAA
reveals that the card enjoys a straight
30 percent lead over gtx 1080 and it's
basically on par with a TI a state of
affairs is fairly common in the standard
benchmarks to come PLSS grants the r-tx
2080 or further 39.5% of raw performance
which clearly takes it well beyond the
capabilities of even the most powerful
Pascal cards with TLS s actively r-tx
20/80 offers an 81 percent boost over
1080 with 2080 results this good the
impacts on the Ti is even more profound
again with DLS s active it's capable of
delivering 80 percent more performance
than the 1080 TI which you know come on
that's pretty awesome
with 28 games confirmed for DLS s
support is clear there is momentum
behind adopting this technology it
requires a game engine that already uses
temporal anti-aliasing which is
basically most of them these days and
according to Nvidia integration is
fairly simple now if we're getting a 40%
performance uplift the implications are
clear here for ray-tracing an area where
low frame rates are concerning a lot of
potential users as I mentioned earlier
so here's an example of its application
at work here
starwars reflection demo bear in mind
that up until the release of cheering it
took for voter cards running in parallel
to render this at 1080p 24 here we're
running the demos unlocked at 1440p with
DL SS on both cards but RT x 2080 TI has
the processing power and the memory to
operate at 2160p 4k using dl SS and
although frame rates are a lot lower it
is doing so consistently above the 24
FPS design threshold this gives you some
idea not only of how ray tracing
capabilities scale between the two RT x
cards but also how instrumental DL SS
could be in getting frame rates and
maybe resolutions higher when RT
features are enabled so we've covered
some examples of how the cheering
architecture aims to improve quality and
performance for new and enhanced
features but the fact is that in many
ways that's all about the future of
gaming technology so what about the
present and indeed the past there's been
a lot of concern obviously about the
lack of performance numbers in the run
up to the RT X launched as Nvidia spent
too much of its time on new features
that may or may not be utilized has ray
tracing and da SAS come at the expense
of standard rasterized 3d performance to
answer this question we've put together
a revised suite of benchmarks a mixture
of old favorites and newcomers based on
the most modern rendering techniques
owing to time pressures we've limited
our results to 4k performance only we
did carry out some testing and lower
resolutions but really none of these
cards should be considered for anything
other than 1440p gaming or higher we'll
kick off with one of digital boundaries
classic favorites Assassin's Creed unity
so tight all that vacuums have both
compute and vram not to mention memory
bandwidth when its depth of field effect
kicks in during cutscenes the results
overall a clear-cut r-tx 20/80 does a
remarkable job of mimicking the
throughput of the outgoing 1080 Ti is
very slightly slower overall on averages
but improves on its lowest 1% figures
meanwhile the arty x28 of Ti
immediately presents its credentials
delivering a solid 30% chunk of extra
performance over both GT X 1080 Ti and
RT X 2018 playing this beautiful game on
top tier RT X hardware and a 4k display
quite the experience next up it's time
to take a look at battlefield one on TX
12 running a small section of campaign
game player ultra settings there is no
canned benchmark on this title meaning
that there can be some variants on a per
round basis however the trend is clear
enough cheering seems to get the most
performance out of the most modern
rendering architectures and this could
be seen here as the RT X 2080 enjoys a
solid 10% lead in frame rates over the
GTX 1080 TI gen versus gen and that's
assuming you consider the 20 88 1080
successor bearing in mind the extra
money being charged to it well the
bottom line is that cheering delivers a
solid 32 percent improvement once again
20 atti who delivers suitably monstrous
results a clear 41 percent boost in
performance compared to GTA X 1080 Ti
and it's just over 28 percent faster
than 2018 further solidifying the TI's
GPU king reputation Crysis 3 is another
oldie but goodie and it's always the
first game I load up whenever a new
graphics card arrives why well first of
all we know of its various
characteristics in stressing every part
of a new GPU secondly while the game may
be over five years old now as display
resolutions have scaled over time Crytek
shooter continues to provide a stern
challenge to any kind of hardware that's
traumatic this game is supremely
challenging to GPU Hardware 4k
resolution and has a particular habit of
revealing specific weaknesses in ugp new
technology and in this case it's showing
that the existing 1080 TI can actually
beat RT X 2018 by a small but
significant margin in some tasks with
the Pascal chip delivering a 4.8%
advantage over all this appears to be an
architectural issue as the percentage
differential with RT X 2018 eats into
the performance bump delivered by 2080
Ti which posts a 25%
crews over its predecessor far cry 5
next a new game in our benchmark suite
and a significant one first of all I did
note that this game's reliance on single
core performance means that the RT x 28
TI can be bottlenecked at 14-14
resolution even with an 18 700 K once
again the 2080 reveals that its general
performance level is very similar indeed
to 1080 Ti and remember that the lead at
command scene may well vanish once cards
and running at reference clocks appear
after all remember that the founders
editions cards do get factory overclocks
this time around on the flip side it's
worth pointing out that cheering
features hardware level HDR tone mapping
something that Pascal does not possess
meaning that if you are playing this one
on a high dynamic range display the RT X
28 and should pull ahead meanwhile it's
business as usual with the RT X 28 etim
there's a twenty nine point five percent
performance increase over the twenty
eighty a performance differential that
increases to 13 three percent up against
the ten agencyís let's continue now with
Ghost Recon wildlands for Ubisoft run
this game on its default high setting
and it's an eminently agreeable
experience across a range of PC hardware
however dip into the quality settings
move to the ultra preset and suddenly
the game transforms into one of the most
challenging graphics workouts we've ever
seen and we're even GT X 1080 T I can
only deliver an anemic 37 FPS at 4k
resolution this remarkably low level
performance persists into the RT x II
era once again RT X 28 e and z in a
small uptick in performance over 10 80
TI though there is a creditable 30% jump
over its predecessor GT X 1080 the RT X
20 80 TI remains the king of the hill
but the crippling workout induced by
this title on this extreme preset
ensures that we get a subpar boost of
just 22% but yeah I would consider this
one an outlier next up the freshly
minted shadow the Tomb Raider
first of all congrats to develop a mixes
for the various
special nature of this piece ink port
the dx12 implementation is stunning and
CPU utilization is phenomenal and it's
one of the very few games we're running
at 1080p doesn't necessarily leave me
struggling with CPU stutter it's also
highly friendly to horizon processors as
well at the low end GTX 1080 and Vegas
64 offer essentially equivalent
experiences but similar to battlefield
one RT X 2080 is able to push ahead of
the classic 1080 TI delivering a nine
percent improvement to overall
performance and that's consistent from
start to finish
meanwhile Jen on Jen's r-tx 2080 offers
up a 38% r15 frame rates over the GTX
1080 the increase in performance on our
TX 2080 Ti is similarly impressive with
a clearer 39 percent improvement in
light for like testing against 1080 TI
while the bump to frame rates is at the
27% mark compared to RTX 2018
of course Nexus isn't finished with
shadow not by a long shot
RT X or a trace shadow support is
incoming but perhaps more exciting is
the arrival of PLSS our performance is
really good here already and it should
be phenomenal once deep learning super
sampling is added to the mix next up we
love our Witcher 3 benchmark our run
through the grounds of novigrad city on
horseback is feci CPU GPU memory
bandwidth and even storage if your frame
rates go high enough everything is run
our ultra settings but we disabled in
video hare words which doesn't really
provide enough of a visual upgrade to
warrant its mammoth GPU costs so there
were some good results here with our TX
2080 delivering a solid 5 percent
increase in performance over the GTX
1080 TI which in turn means that the 20
80 TI delivers a really decent 37% of
additional 3 per our final benchmark
tests gain is a really good one mu from
Stein
to the new Colossus running under EdTech
6 on the Vulkan API to say this game is
a performance monster is not an
understatement stretches of gameplay at
uber settings on the r-tx 28 ET i can
play out in excess of a hundred and
twenty frames per second
there's no canned benchmark around for
this one so we choose a dash through the
battle torn streets of New Orleans to
put this game through its paces
RTX takes this to the next level and
highlights how more modern game engines
sing on the cheering architecture 2080
posts its biggest increase over ten atti
to date delivering a 17 percent uptick
in performance compared to the gtx 1080
that boost zips up to a remarkable 48
percent in the here-and-now r-tx 2018 is
very much a similar product in standard
reading performance two gtx 1080i but
maybe this highlights the state of
performance improvements to come now
what's all the more remarkable here is
that I'm told that the current build of
move 2 does not include securing
specific variable rate shading
optimizations we saw during Nvidia's
press staging Gamescom so there may be
further improvements to come all of
which bodes well for RTX 28 ET i it's
already phenomenal here posting a 50%
improvement in frame rates over gtx
1080i
so what's the score here cheering
represents the biggest shift in PC
graphics technology we've seen for a
long time possibly even stretching back
to the arrival of GeForce 3 architecture
back in the day there is much in common
here specifically more for focus on
introducing new features dedicating
precious silicon die space to amazing
stuff like real-time ray tracing
acceleration and deep learning as
opposed to just piling on more cuda
cores and you know this was always an
option for Nvidia and it would
undoubtedly have led to bigger
performance increases in standard 3d
gaming and possibly lower prices but
fundamentally it would be more of the
same another product defined by how much
faster it is than its predecessor as
opposed to delivering something
genuinely new and forward-looking
cheering represents a new vision for
gaming technology one that alized
closely with Nvidia's aspirations in
data center processing and the
automotive markets
now on the face of it there's little
need for chewings deep-learning tents
applause to be part of a Geforce product
however the arrival of DL SS seems to
address the relevancy of the tents of
cause by providing what looks like a
killer feature we're still waiting for
actual games to test but based on the
two demos we've tried Nvidia's take on
reprojection is delivering 35 to 40
percent of additional performance and
that's a crucial component in setting
apart the r-tx 2080 from the gtx to an
80 TI which still holds up remarkably
well in standard 3d gaming but in the
here and now there is the sense that a
lot of what cheering offers will only
manifest in the future there'll be no
irate face games available at the RT X
launch couple of demos if we're lucky
and even DL SS gaming may take a little
time to arrive so in that sense it's
perfectly understandable if we decide to
hold back on purchase for now that said
we fully understand that this may well
prove challenging when GT X 1080 TI
remains competitive in traditional 3d
rendering and when prices on that card
may well tumble when our TX pricing
already looks extreme a cut-price 1080 T
I could just prove too tempting and
pricing clearly is the biggest issue
here but equally the cost of making the
product has clearly risen significantly
just in terms of dye size alone before
we factor in the g6 memory and the much
higher quality chassis and thermal
solution and this also takes place in an
era where flagship phones regularly seen
price increases and even Xbox one X
pushed the envelope uncomfortably in
terms of its price point the bottom line
is that the pace of technological
evolution is slowing down and prices
generally arising and obviously the lack
of competition in the GPU space clearly
isn't helping deciding whether to invest
so much money in a high-energy thingy
requires careful thought then what I can
say is it in the short term Pascal
products are still superb and the
potential of curing is only just
beginning to be tapped into questions
remain over the take-up of King Features
but I suspect we'll be a lot more
knowledgeable about late facing and DL
SS support within the next few months in
the here and now the pricing is clearly
going to be a sticking point for many
but the fact is that NVIDIA is the first
firm to step up with a vision for the
future of gaming technology producing
results that nothing on the market can
copy so anyway I hope you really enjoyed
this video and as always do like and
subscribe to support our work and ring
the bell if subbed for instant
notifications when a new video drops and
yes please do consider the df' patreon
to support the team and to get access to
some exclusive goodies but that's all
from me for now thanks for watching